In this final section of our course, we will go over the workflow for importing and setting up body correctives that have been created using the PoseDriverConnect toolset.
We will first go over the plugin that is needed to bring the RBF solvers into Unreal Engine.
And then we will jump back into Unreal Engine one last time to go over the steps for importing and assigning them to the metahuman body.
So let's begin by going over the required plugin.
The PoseDriverConnect toolset allows users to author their own corrective poses.
And the PoseDriverConnect plugin allows users to import the poses into Unreal Engine.
From there, they can be applied using an animation blueprint.
The plugin is located in the FAP marketplace.
Begin by installing it to the appropriate engine version.
Then inside of Unreal Engine, open up the plugins menu and enable the PoseDriverConnect plugin and restart the engine.
Now let's jump back into Unreal Engine one last time to go over the steps for importing and assigning the body correctives.
Inside of Unreal Engine, to import and assign the body correctives, let's first navigate to the Atomic Savage example body folder.
I will open up the metahuman folder.
Then go to the Atomic Savage example folder and then to the body folder.
The first step is to create a folder for the corrective poses.
I have already created a folder named RBF Solvers EX for example.
I will open this.
Now the next step is to create an animation blueprint.
I have already created one and named it RBF Correctives EX for example.
But to walk you through the steps, right click in an empty space.
Then select Animation and then select Animation Blueprint.
In this pop-up window, assign the metahuman base skeleton and then select Create.
I am going to cancel this since I have already gone through these steps.
Now let's double click on this to open it.
I will dock this up here.
Inside of here, I am going to navigate to the Preview tab up here on the right.
For the mesh, I am going to search for the Atomic S body skin weights skeletal mesh and select it.
And then I will click on Apply to Asset over here.
In the Anom Graph, I am going to right click and search for Input Pose and select it.
I am going to connect it to the Output Pose and then I will zoom out and drag the Input Pose all the way over here.
I will now compile and save this.
Next, I will go back to the main viewport.
I will go up here to Tools and go down here and select Pose Driver Connect.
In the Pose Driver Connect panel, for the Retarget Source Asset, I am going to use the drop-down arrow
and then locate the Atomic S body skin weights skeletal mesh.
It is right here, so I will select it.
For the Animation Blueprint, I am going to assign the Animation Blueprint I have over here named RBF Solvers Example.
Next, we need to assign the RBF JSON file.
I will go here and in File Explorer, up here I will paste the location of the source files folder of our course.
In the Pose Driver Connect folder, inside of the folder named RBF Solvers, I am going to select the JSON file named Solver Data and then select Open.
For the FBX Source Directory, I am going to paste the location of the source files folder up here again and then open the Pose Driver Connect folder.
I will then select the RBF Solvers folder and then select Open.
For the FBX Import Directory, I will go to the MetaHumans folder, then to the Atomic Savage Example folder, then select the RBF Solvers Example folder.
Now I can select Import All RBF Solvers. This will take a moment.
Now that everything has been imported, I am going to save everything.
If we go to the Animation Blueprint now, inside of the Anim Graph, we will see that the body correctives have been added in here and are all connected.
All we need to do now is compile and save.
I will return back to the main viewport and if we want to view a body corrective, I will double click on this one to open it.
In the Preview Scene panel, for the Preview Mesh, I will use the drop-down arrow to search for the Atomic-S Skeletal Mesh and I will select it.
And then I will select Apply to Asset.
Now if I scrub through this animation, we can't really tell if the corrective is applied, so we will want to make sure that the Animation Blueprint is assigned to this Skeletal Mesh.
I will go back to the main viewport, then in the Content Browser down here, I will go all the way down past all of these correctives and select the Animation Blueprint.
With this selected, I will go back to the Animation Sequence window and in the Preview Mesh section, I will use the folder icon to browse to the Skeletal Mesh.
I will open this up and over here in the Asset Details panel, I would assign the Animation Blueprint here in the Post Process Animation Blueprint slot.
Now before I do this, in the Skeleton Tree, I'm going to select the left upper arm and then rotate it.
Now when I assign the Animation Blueprint over here, we can see what the upper arm area looks like when a corrective pose is applied.
And this is how you import and assign body corrective poses to a custom metahuman body.
Now let's do a quick review of these steps and wrap up our course.
With the PostDriverConnect plugin enabled in the Unreal Engine project, create a folder for the RBF solvers to be added to when they are imported.
Next, create an Animation Blueprint and assign the metahuman-based Skeleton to it.
Inside of the Animation Blueprint, in the Preview Scene, assign the Custom Body Skeletal Mesh and then select Apply to Asset.
In the AnomGraph, add an InputPose node and connect it to the OutputPose.
Then drag the InputPose node away from the OutputPose to make room for the pose drivers.
The next step is to import the pose drivers.
To import the body correctives, in the MainView port go to Tools and select PoseDriverConnect.
In the PoseDriverConnect panel, assign the Skeletal Mesh and Animation Blueprint.
Then set the path directories for the RBF JSON file, the FBX Source directory, and the FBX Import directory where you want them to be added.
Next, open up the Animation Blueprint, Compile and Save.
For the last step, assign the Animation Blueprint to the Skeletal Mesh.
Inside of the Skeletal Mesh window, in the Asset Details panel, locate the Post Process Animation Blueprint slot and assign the Animation Blueprint.
From there, you can test and see if the solvers are working.
You can also open up the Animation Sequence window and play each corrective solver from the Asset Browser.
In the Preview Scene panel, assign the Skeletal Mesh and select Apply to Asset so that you can see the pose driver on the target Skeletal Mesh and update the thumbnail image.
Now that we have gone through all of the steps for importing and assigning corrective poses for the body, let's wrap up this course with some resources that may be helpful.
All of the online resources and links to some of the tools discussed today can be found by following the URLs on this slide.
Feel free to pause here or take a screenshot for later reference.
In the Resources section, you will find links to the DNA Calibration Repository on GitHub and the 2023 DNA Calibration Deep Dive Demonstration.
There is also a link to the Pose Driver Connect plugin on FAB and a tutorial on how to use the Pose Driver Connect Tool Set from the Epic Games Developer Community.
This brings us to the end of the MetaHuman DNA Calibration and Finalization course.
As mentioned at the beginning of the course, with newer engine versions, some of the MetaHuman customization workflows have changed,
and we will explore the new workflows in a future update.
I want to thank you for spending your time with me and I hope that these videos help you as you continue working with MetaHumans in Unreal Engine.